STEWART BRAND: Luigi asks: The issue of trust between
humans and autonomous systems is not a
new one.
what sort of features or AI interactions
might increase trust in both directions?
IAN MCEWAN: Well, it's a very good question, I really
don't know the answer. What would increase our
trust? I wrote a short story in order to
get going on this novel. It's a
fivefinger exercise. And it's written
from far in the future looking back when
artificial humans have become so
stitched into life. And they served on
juries, and they served in the military.
They had rights and responsibilities. And
gradually we went back to 19th century
anti-slavery laws, and using much of that
language, in order to say you cannot own
such a person.
I mean owning another human being is, I
think, a bad in itself. And then it became
non, very non-pc, to ask someone when
you're sitting at dinner with some
strangers, to say: are you real? It'd be extremely
rude. And my narrator in that short story
had lived that transition. That it
would be just as intrusive as if you
were to say it dinner loudly, "I hear
you've got a colostomy bag. Bad luck."
To say of someone, "Are you real?" is sort of
physically intrusive. Because you've
already accepted that they are
conscious, so what should it matter?
And so it starts with a man who's
with his girlfriend. They're making love
and he feels he has to ask her. And
the story really is all about her answer.
And I I think coming back to this
question: That would then be, once we
passed that point of even not even
wanting, let alone daring, to ask,
then we would have reached the point of
total trust. BRAND: Oh, interesting.
MCEWAN: That would be the the meeting point.